okay now what I have done is I've set up
my Cartesian planes I've put HK and
pretty much the same spot for every
single graph just so my brain doesn't go
crazy okay but HK can be anywhere we
like I put them all in the first
quadrant but they could be over in
second third fourth it could be on one
of the coordinate axes wherever we want
them to be that's the point of calling
it H okay now let's go through them in
order I'm gonna go up down left right
okay so the up down one is the easiest
with someone where most familiar with
but then what we want to think about is
well where are the other features where
are the important bits okay so the focus
is an natural place to begin if I place
the focus somewhere like here because I
know the focal length for all of these
parabolas is all they're all equal to
eight right I need to go from the vertex
and in this case go up eight units so
what happens to the x-coordinate stays
the same so it's still H and then the
y-coordinate becomes K plus a in much
the same way when I'm trying to work out
the directrix it's in the same
orientation but the opposite direction
so it's gonna be down here it's
horizontal so it's gonna be y equals and
that will be y equals now hold on I
don't need to supply any x coordinate
here because all the effort ordinates
I've got all the x coordinates so I just
look at the y coordinate it'll be from
the vertex and then you go down the
focal length okay now everything will
look very familiar but reversed when I
do the down parabola over here because
you can see in this case the focus is
all over the vertex
again the x coordinate doesn't change
but this time it's K minus a you've just
gone down instead of up and same but
opposite for our good old directrix up
here yeah same but opposite you know
same same but different
okay now when you have a look at your
or by the way it's probably useful if
you've got I don't how many cause you've
got mines kind of a yeah I'm going I'm
going out of Eric's shirt here cuz you
know decades today if you've got another
color I often think about going from the
vertex up to the focus down to the
directrix or if you reversed down to the
focus up to the directrix and that like
positioning that you see them all there
in a row is a really important feature
again okay we'll do the rest of this
quick up this guy is going to be concave
right because everything's positive and
that's the positive direction so off he
goes where's the focus going to be it's
a units to the right somewhere like here
so being that I've gone to the right now
it's the x-coordinate the changes so
it's going to be h plus a very good why
core doesn't change and then rinse and
repeat for the directrix but it's not
why cuz anymore is it it's gonna be
because it's a vertical line H and then
you went to the left by that focal
distance and lucky lost
oops bless you focus has shifted this
way and directrix
has gone this way okay are you happy do
you see how I'm understanding everything
in relation to each other so into the
parabola to find the focus out of a
parabola to get the directrix you put
your focus in you put your dread tricks
out it's not that hard okay if you have
the picture you'll be fine okay
right so there's 9c maybe you're still
in 9 8 or 9 B that's okay but the key is
draw the picture just like in circle
geometry if you come and ask me a
question and you don't have a picture I
will send you away ok draw the thing and
you'll be fine okay